[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
today's question comes from Sandra in
Florida Sandra writes my spouse's
spending is crippling our finances and
our marriage each month we have only
about 5 to 600 left after monthly bills
and minimum debt payments and we only
have $1,000 saved I've tried to speak
lovingly to my husband and let him know
how much the overspending scares me and
affects my mental health I've also had
moments of frustration have blamed him
for financial struggles which I realize
is not a healthy approach seems all my
efforts and approaches are futile I
understand the ramsy principles behind
join accounts and have lived this way
for years but at what point in my
marriage do I say enough and separate
myself financially right before divorce
yeah yeah and I think we're here I think
we're close this is way bigger Dave than
uh I'm glad she I'm glad she had the
courage to write is crippling our
finances and our marriage because this
type of behavior tells me there's other
issues in that marriage it's not just
money yeah this guy is um kind of got
the axis of the world stopped through
the top of his head everything spins
around him he's the most important thing
that ever lived I'm telling you his mama
told him that yep and um and now uh
nobody tells him
anything yeah
um I just can't imagine Dave I again I
don't have a psychology for this I can't
imagine Sheila taking me out and saying
um anything I'm doing you're scaring me
to
death and me going yeah I don't care I I
I I
just I don't have that in my I don't
have that in my body I understand that I
don't understand how you could respond
to to anybody that way if if the if the
waitress at at Waffle House sat down and
said hey the way you're doing things
scares me and I I'm not I don't feel
safe I I don't think I could be like I
don't care like I I I just don't have
that in me man so I don't understand
this dude at all what a scumbag I just
don't get it don't get it so
um yeah it could be just immaturity
could be a lot of things um in all
seriousness all once I get past all my
frustration and my name calling but um
the
um so there's two issues with this email
number one uh you guys need to sit down
with a marriage counselor and if he
won't go go by yourself so that you can
start to get language to how you're
going to decide how much longer you're
going to do this uh because my
experience with this and I'm not a
counselor and I'm not trained like John
is but for 30 years I've done this and
sat with couples and my experien is
particularly ladies more so than men uh
they reach an end point
and it boils and boils and boils and
then suddenly they go over the edge and
the switch flips and once it flips
there's no getting her back right she
done when she's done she like like
roadkill it's over it's done and you
can't get it back and you're going to
reach that boiling point and if you
don't do it intentionally with some help
with a good coach a good marriage
counselor to give you words to do this
in a very wise and reasonable way it's
all it's sneak up on you and him and
you're just going to go I'm done when
somebody says the word futile everything
I've tried yeah is for not is for
nothing now that's lost hope that's lost
hope that's right yeah and uh so you're
you're getting really close and I'm
telling you if there's a chance that you
save this marriage it's going to be with
some help guiding you through how to
communicate to him if you can get
through to Jello brain here and get him
to do this okay now if you can and you
turn it around that's great that's
that's thing one that's the route to
go hidden inside of this email is the
question that I've been asked a bunch of
times is a separate issue this how can I
handle my money separately in a messed
up marriage and it be okay and the
answer is you can't you've got to make
the marriage okay if you want to have
prosperity in your relationships and
prosperity in your net worth it has to
be done from a functional standpoint not
surviving a bunch of misbehavior and
still prospering in spite of it that
just doesn't happen in my experience we
we see almost never does someone
overcome this guy not changing and
somehow you create a tactical way to
separate your money and while you're
still married to him and he continues to
do the exact same thing somehow you go
off and become a millionaire that does
not happen
that's just that's mythology there's not
a tactic a legal document a process that
causes you to be able to swim with an
anchor around your
ankle and and so you guys have got to
work through this or work your way out
of it to be able to have a great life
for both of you and he's I think it's
important to call out this husband is
not um being a person of fidelity he is
not upholding the marriage vows that
said till sickness um to sickness and
health um till death do his part um this
is ours mine is yours and yours is mine
he's not doing that um he's saying I
really don't care about you I just don't
I just don't create your free every
dooll budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life